we do have good news though there is a
phrase i'm sure most of you have uh have
heard
get woke go broke oh yeah check this
story out from bounding into comics
new rumor claims that falcon and the
winter soldier viewers
turned off the show after black lives
matter messaging
um before we even get in this i'm just
going to say i believe it
so there was there was there was this
meme uh i would say was me it was some
data that was posted on reddit where it
was like
critic reviews versus audience review
disparities so
it was like a data reddit and you can
see where movies where the critics said
it was bad but the audience said it was
good
and movies where the critics said it was
good and the audience said was bad
captain marvel was one of them
captain marvel is rotten according to
the audience
but fresh according to the the critics
surprise surprise so here's the story
they say this well those are familiar
the the falcon in the winter soldier is
one of those new shows on disney plus
they say a relatively new rumor claims
that viewers of the recently released
falcon in the winter soldier
turned it off after the show featured
black lives matter messaging
they say overlord dvd claims that a
source communicated to him
that the tune out time stamp for the
second episode of
the falcon winter soldier revealed
viewers stopped watching the show before
the episode ended
as explained by overlord dvd tots is
logged at tots is uh
time stamp what is it tune out timestamp
is logged on disney plus whenever a
viewer stops watching a particular movie
or television episode
it's useful to the bean counters at
disney plus to note when they lose a
particular viewer
because this can give them valuable data
about how the show is doing and what the
viewer thinks about
it goes on a state the source claims
that around 5 pm on saturday across the
board
the time out tune the the timeout tune
stamp is that way
the tune out time stamp they got it for
the second episode of the falcon this
winter soldier went crazy
with people turning off the show in
droves all around the same part of the
show within seconds
that part of the show apparently they
show this image
where the cops pull up to sam and bucky
now bucky's a white dude sam's a black
dude
and the cops are like is there a problem
sir to the to bucky who's white
and he's like no he's my friend they're
like are you all right what's he doing
and then he's like don't you know who
this is and they're like what that's the
falcon and they go
oh i'm so sorry i saw that
and i was just like dude come on that's
subtle though that was really scary
yeah i'm missing this who's the falcon
the falcon yeah
not not the broads no i don't know who
the falcon is but is the falcon the
white guy or the black guy
okay yeah and they were like have
reverence for this guy and everyone else
the cops pulled up and they saw a white
guy in a black eye arguing
and then asked the white guy if he was
all right and if he needed help because
of this black guy
because he fit the profile yeah he was a
superhero
at it and then bucky is like don't you
know who that is
he's like that's the falcon and then the
cop goes like oh geez i didn't realize
they were doing this you know yeah
the very kind of over the head a little
bit
that's the problem they can't keep it
out of the culture i mean breitbart said
the greatest thing you know
politics is downstream from culture all
right that's what they do is they inject
those things into the culture
and they expect people not to notice
here's the problem they are so
unsubtle these days trump made them so
crazy
that they ripped the masks off and they
stopped being subtle and now they're
just beating you over the head about it
wow
people don't like that trump was the
artistic trojan horse
he got in there and just caused the
entertainment industry to go haywire
or the giant stink bomb let off in the
room or whatever you want to call it but
he made them so angry they stopped being
good
at their pr game check this out they're
going to say the source says quote
my jaw hit the floor i couldn't believe
what i was seeing all
the turnout was at the cop scene where
it clearly shows
they were ready to pull their guns on a
black guy arguing with a white guy it's
clear this was the message he goes on to
state so in other words disney felt like
sticking a black lives matter message
smack dab in the middle of falcon and
winter soldier episode 2
and what do you know apparently fans who
are sick to death of bad news and tragic
headlines decided they had enough and
turned the episode off
overlord dvd claims according to his
source over the course of friday and
saturday
a full 79.9 percent of people that were
tuning in stopped watching at that point
in the story
the number would apparently increase of
the next few days as well according to
this source over the next few days
the average went up to 83.49 percent
overall
that means 83.49 of viewers turned off
the episode
at almost exactly the same woke point he
adds the source claims
there were also a lot of subsequent
cancellations happening in real time
maybe it's not a real source maybe it's
not good information i don't know it's
it's rumor
it's rumor it makes me feel good nothing
else
and here's the nice thing we can play
information warfare yeah that's actually
definitive i heard a guy say that too
there is no disney guy is now in my ear
right now telling me that that's fact
that that like um that like uh what
would you call it
enhances my love for humanity my belief
that humanity is
awake aware and wise if that's real the
get well go brook stuff yeah the people
just got no time for this junk i was
just watching family guy earlier
and it's one of the older episodes where
uh joe who's the cop
you guys know family guy he pulls up and
then you know peter is sitting on the
couch and he hears on a megaphone it's
the police you know come out with your
hands up or something
peter goes outside and he sees cleveland
quagmire and joe
in a swat van and he's like wow what's
this
and then joe's like come on we're going
for a beer run in this new police van
the next scene that shows them in the
police van and then joe goes
the van is equipped with the latest
police technology he says peter stand in
the circle peter walks into a circle and
then also an arms come down and goes
you are under arrest and then it grabs
his hands and cuffs him you have the
right to remain silent
and then peter goes wow cool and then
cleveland goes let me try cleveland of
course being the black character
and joe goes cleveland no wait don't and
then two arms come down with batons and
start beating him going
minority suspect found and then when
quagmire falls to the ground they go oh
no
he has a gun and then it
that was really funny it was it's an old
family guy joke
that's one way to incorporate these
ideas in humor
that most people would laugh about
because it's not asserting necessarily
as a truth it's not like a scene
in an action drama where the cops are
going after a superhero
oh no because they're racist it was
making a joke about racism
while being very very subtle and funny
about it um and robert downey jr in
tropic thunder did you guys see that
movie
i was just watching the interview with
him and rogan last night again and he
was talking about it
and how it's still he hasn't been you
know because that
that movie was making fun of the actors
that would play that character of
blackface he wasn't playing blackface he
was playing a white guy that was
in blackface and it was very obvious how
how ridiculous
it it can be and that's what family guy
does in a lot of ways
and it's crowder does in a lot of ways
they cancel him for it they try to
cancel him for it but if they're if they
got back to that like it's when jon
stewart started doing the news
and he became essentially cnn for the
left and when he was doing the daily
show
he would play clown nose on clown nose
off it was never
off right it was all clown nose yeah and
because of that
he inserted so much leftist propaganda
and
viewpoints that he could never get in
and get people to listen to in a
straight news shot but jon stewart was
honest
he was jon stewart praised project
veritas on more than one occasion
they wouldn't do that today they
wouldn't because jon stewart recognized
he had his opinion well i'll put it this
way jon stewart was a guy who has his
opinions were liber
he had liberal opinions but he was an
honest guy about his opinions
uh that's why i thought the daily show
was awesome with him so when project
veritas did the whole acorn sting
he was like journalists where are you
this dude's pulling off major journalism
what's going on and he shows james
o'keefe in the pimp out and all that
stuff
and then later on he also praised him
you know in another in another
circumstance
imagine don lemon and brian stelter
being like
these conservative journalists are doing
a great job now never going to happen
they've gone past they've gone over the
top in their own beliefs and it's it's
partly
because now they're so angry they can't
see that it's not working
and it is working all right it's working
for a large segment of the population
who doesn't have the time
to break through the haze but now you've
got alternative sources of information
like what we're doing right here and
other places for now
for now but so what you're building
you're building subscription it's
brilliant
it's a brilliant idea to tell people hey
they're coming for all of us
and point out they're coming for you too
all right whoever you are out there
right now they're coming for you in some
way shape or form
get on board and fight back because
that's what we're doing and this is
important too because i'm
it's going to be a shout out for
timcast.com but it's also an important
point about what you can do and what
we're doing
so we set up timcast.com initially just
like okay we need a place to put content
in the event we get banned because
facebook actually put a restriction on
my my page and now that page is
basically defunct
so we start teamcast.com we're going to
do bonus segments for everybody we got a
bunch of new members and i said okay
let's build an even better website let's
let's
streamline it update the upgrade the
graphics and make it look better
and then i was like we need to actually
make culture so i got a script i got i'm
sorry not a script i got a treatment
a proposal for a show sent to me by a
comedian we want to make a sitcom i said
let's do it
let's make a sitcom maybe maybe we'll
try and get it on a mainstream streaming
service or maybe i'll just put on
timcast.com because i'll tell you
i want to create a website where we just
do comedy specials we do sitcoms we do
drama we do movies we do video games
we just start building the culture
that's been taken over by the woke
vice man when i i remember why i wanted
to why i wanted to go to vice why
i talked to them and i said i'd like to
work here
because they were edgy they were regular
people they were crazy
yeah yeah absolutely but they they'd go
you know look you had ryan duffy's
bulletproof clothing
he goes down to meet this crazy guy
who's like i make clothes that are
bulletproof and they actually shoot
he's wearing this trench coat super
heavy and thick and you know bulletproof
those were fun and exciting stories
where some regular guy
who was off the cuff kind of punk rock
sex drugs and rock and roll were going
on these adventures
now it's woke ultra woke it's as
establishment as it comes
it's boring mainstream corporate garbage
we need to bring back fun exciting
and you know we need to bring back punk
rock man i think it's
the brilliant i love when we claim now
that conservatism is punk rock
you know now that it's being a lot of it
is let's just make it anti-war because
everybody gets hung up on things i don't
want to be conservative i'm not a
republican you know okay
neither am i but i am anti-woke
all right i'm based whatever you want to
call it well the lefties are based as
well
yeah i'm shooting white pills whatever
whatever you want to characterize it as
we're punk rock we are now the rebels
we're the anti-establishment
so weird isn't it yeah i love last night
we had brandon tatum on the show um
officer brantanum he's no longer enough
uh police officer and we were talking
about
running away from a fight and he was
saying where he grew up you were thought
of as a punk
if you would turn a run and he kept
saying punk and it crossed my mind a
couple times that like
yo punk rock it is punk to run away from
a fight
that's punk rock no no no that's not
what he was saying he was saying you
were getting punked
yeah he was using the same word punk and
it's like that word synonym
sometimes that word has negative
connotations but in reality it's cool to
be punk
you it's cool to turn and run and avoid
a fight like that's punk rock dude
a physical fight you might choose to
avoid yeah
a battle of ideas and a culture war you
need
to know well like you said you don't
play their level man you you stay punk
you stay on your level now you yeah
because if you do that i definitely
think that analogy is missing missing
out what we're doing is literally
fighting back as hard as we can
well like you said if someone's like
well what about z
you just keep talking about why but
that's still fighting you're just not
letting them dictate the time i'm not
the fight right that's not rock i'm
going to violate your rules that i'm
punk you know i'm not going to fight the
alligator underwater like you said
i'm not going to stand on land and be
like you want to go i'm up here on the
drag the chicken
up the bank and when the alligator gets
out there i'll beat him to death
that's what we're going to do but he's
still going to fight it because he's
evil and i want him done and he's trying
to shut us down
i'm going to starve him out or something
yeah there's other ways to win a war i'm
talking about punk rock in the sense
of fighting the establishment and
telling the
the the the the nerds the boring people
the authoritarians the npcs to buzz off
we're going to do our thing we're going
to make fun exciting content young
people
are going to want to be a part of it
they're going to be inspired by it by
the talent
by the by the enterprise and they're
going to look to these woke boring
teachers who tell them what they can or
can't do and they're going to be like i
choose
freedom so no laugh track no
definitely okay good have a live
audience just have enough of it no no
it's it's
like it's going to be it's going to like
i mean maybe we could do a laugh track
on purpose for no i just
brooklyn nine-nine we're we're it's
gonna be a modern modern show
it's gonna be that should be the name of
it too modern show the modern
comedy show perfect no no this is a
pitch for it it's already it's someone
else's project i started getting
already got an outline and so i'm asking
i'm being asked to fund it
and i was like i'll buy the show you
make it we'll put it on timcats.com
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time